ihr feiern
du bist gefeuert ja so hast Donald Trump
ja immer in seiner berühmten Fernsehshow
via printes gemacht du bist raus ja und
in etwa so hat es der neue Twitter Boss
Elon Musk gemacht der feuert nämlich
sein komplettes Management der
Finanzvorstand raus der Oberchef weg und
auch die für alle Rechtsfragen
zuständige Frau die sie hier im Bild
sehen ebenfalls gefeuert die Donald
Trump auch hat sperren lassen damals
alle weg mit denen und das am ersten Tag
nach dem Musk bei Twitter eingeritten
ist sozusagen liefer ja rein marschierte
er rein mit dem Waschbecken in der Hand
ins Twitter Headquarter und dann hat er
in der Kantine noch ein bisschen
gequatscht mit den neuen Kollegen sehen
Sie die Fotos von dort aus der Coffeebar
und dann schreibt er anschließend bei
Twitter der neue Boss von Twitter der
Vogel er ist befreit the bird is Fried
ja gestern hat er noch geschrieben
letzte tankin zieh dir das rein und
jetzt ist der Vogel befreit also Elon
Musk offiziell der neue twitter-chef und
er schreibt der Grund weshalb ich
Twitter gekauft habe ist dass es wichtig
für die Zukunft der Menschheit ist einen
gemeinsamen digitalen Marktplatz zu
haben wo eine Reihe von Vorstellungen
debattiert werden können ohne dass sie
in Gewalt Enden sagte ja also er spricht
für die große Meinungsfreiheit ein
Zeichen für die Meinungsfreiheit auf der
Welt das jetzt der Milliardär Elon Musk
Twitter gekauft hat ist das so Sebastian
Geißler unser Politik Reporter bei Bild
live jetzt im Studio schönen guten Tag
Sebastian also guter Tag für die
Meinungsfreiheit oder nein ich bin
gesagt geneigt zu sagen jawohl das ist
ein guter Tag für die Meinungsfreiheit
zumindest unter der Voraussetzung dass
er das jetzt umsetzt was er angekündigt
hat nämlich Meinungen wieder sehr viel
freier zuzulassen bei Twitter bei
Twitter ist ja so das funktioniert
technisch oder ist ein Algorithmus
dahinter und da werden Meinungen auch
weg blockt wenn die von Nutzern gemeldet
werden manchmal haben sich dann so
Schwärme so Mops richtig
zusammengefunden die sich verabredet
haben Mensch wir schießen mal gegen die
gegen diese bestimmte Person melden die
ganzen Tweets dann wird das erstmal
blockiert da muss die Person erstmal ein
Anwalt einschalten sie irgendwie an
Twitter melden wird gesperrt von Twitter
kommt da vielleicht irgendwann wieder
wenn das juristisch durch ist diese
ganze Praxis das will Musk weg haben
sondern freie Meinung innerhalb
bestimmter Grenzen ist auch klar man
darf natürlich jetzt nicht trotzdem da
jemanden irgendwie persönlich beleidigen
oder so etwas er hat auch gesagt er will
Twitter zu einer zu einer Wurm and
welcomeing place machen also irgendwie
warm und angenehm ist es bisher nicht ja
Kontroverse Meinung einerseits will
haben aber dann war man welcomeing wie
er das hinkriegt da bin ich sehr
gespannt heißt es jetzt dass eventuell
gesperrte Personen auch wieder zurück
dürfen bei Twitter Donald Trump ich
denke schon er hat gesagt zum Thema
Donald Trump er fand die Sperre damals
schon moralisch falsch und dämlich oder
so das war klarer Ansage deswegen wäre
er so eine Person die dann
möglicherweise wieder zugelassen wird
tatsächlich danke an unseren
politikreporter Sebastian Geister der
sich schon mal die Twitter Farben
Krawatte heute angezogen hat danke dir
[Musik]